just back from Dubai observing the
battle between Airbus and Boeing first
hand is John Strickland from JLS
consulting so John this is these are all
orders for narrow-body aircraft um it
really suggests that low-cost travel is
set for some explosive growth well it
certainly isn't the biggest growth
segment of a market I think both
manufacturers realized this and Vivi's
were somewhat unexpected orders when
they would ask today I left there last
night thinking everything was over and
done with and woke up today back in the
UK and these orders were on the books or
indigo partners that you mentioned is a
major venture capitalists and they
invest particularly in low-cost carriers
and they other the pedigree low-cost
carriers they've been a previous
investor in Ryanair they invested was
their Volaris in Mexico and was there
for example it's because some major
low-cost carrier the least of you is
profitable and successful so this is a
significant order indigo doesn't mess
about late they order because obviously
they believe in the capability of the
others 320 family for their portfolio
Airlines now similarly flydubai which is
the the low-cost carrier of Dubai along
with the promoting long-haul Emirates is
it's looking a massive expansion I mean
I looked at either one of their new max
aircraft in Dubai which is very
impressive they've currently only got
about 50 to 60 aircraft in the fleet so
this order of 225 means we're going to
see massive expansion for them and I
think the range which fits max achive
gives them and when you put it in Dubai
we'll really see them expand their
network look at the Indigo dia is quite
interesting you've got various airlines
including was there Hugh mentioned all
placing orders at the same time that's
quite unusual isn't it it is quite
unusual but there's at this cost buying
power and doing that if indigo can go in
with all these elements together the
strength in terms of their position in
production and unit costs gives them a
better price deal and the manufacturer
of course Airbus is more willing to do
that because it also gives them
certainty of production in volume and
over a period of time there's a lot of
people over here will be asking will
these orders for Airbus mean more UK
manufacturing jobs are at least as many
as we currently have well I should
actually both will create jobs for the
UK certainly the UK because is it a key
partner in Airbus but also many sub
suppliers for Boeing too so both these
orders are helpful to the
economy now the other big story was that
Emirates refused to finalize a deal for
the a380 superjumbo when was that well
that's a being the kind of contentious
point of the Air Show is expected to
open with that announcement in fact what
happened was Emirates held a press
conference and it was Boeing who got the
order for the wide-body 787 which is
it's a long haul wide bodied playing but
much smaller than 380 there's a kind of
symbiotic relationship between Emirates
and Airbus on the 380 Emirates has
already seen its profitability boosted
enormously by the 380 it suits her
business model well with a powerful hub
in Dubai but Airbus absolutely needs
Emirates without them there the Airbus
a380 wouldn't have had as the successor
has but success has been there in terms
of sales because of Emirates but not in
terms of profitability and there's
always been a worry in recent times they
made close production now Emirates I
think has said we're not going to do
this deal just yet we want to do it but
if you're going to close a production
line that leaves us exposed so you've
got to give us some sort of Copperbottom
guarantees that will not happen